i hear
the cdc vouching even doctors who
advocate early treatment refer to some
effectiveness of the mrna vaccines
however when i look in the literature
for such evidence all i can find is a
statistical study that includes
vaccinated individuals and cohorts so
young that they are very unlikely to be
at risk for hospitalization or death i
haven't yet seen a study just focusing
on 60-plus year-olds at risk comparing
vaccinate to the unvaccinated in that
age group how have you found one am i
thinking about this problem correctly
thanks love you guys you've really
helped me get through these past two
years and remain somewhat sane
um so i would point to
can you share my screen or can you not
oh yeah no i think so laptop screen alt
l is that what that alt lowercase l
um
yeah look at that so we linked to this
this is this is our friend that's not
his real name
um dr rollygator
we linked to this in the cupboard piece
that uh
that we published on my sub stack back
at the very end of july of last year
and i have not reviewed what his
arguments are
and they are
for this so i'm not i'm not going to try
to summarize but
um
he
here actually i can't look at my notes
because i don't have my screen so you
wanna give me my screen back
um
go go there and what he finds is i
believe um
that actually for the oldest cohort
there may be
a benefit
and what he finds is no evidence of
benefit
for um all of the younger cohorts
including you know
like including people i can't remember
what his number of age
groups is like
um for the over 65-year group there
appears to be some some benefit and for
everyone else
he finds no evidence of benefit so i
would i would try there
no gators are not lizards actually no
reptiles though
true true
okay i was recently infected with
coca-19 i went to a local hospital to
receive a monoclonal antibody infusion i
was in a waiting room with other
coronavirus patients waiting for the
same treatment they went around asking
each patient some basic registration
questions including their vaccination
status
there was i'm going to ask you to show
my screen again in a minute sorry
there was a grand total of one person in
the room who was unvaccinated
meanwhile the official statistics from
new york state are still saying that
breakthrough cases are the exception and
that most infections are in unvaccinated
people what is going on are they
manipulating the data or is it just that
the population eligible for monoclonal
antibodies is more likely to get
vaccinated because of the higher risk
interesting um
i mean it could be both of course i
rather suspect it maybe both but someone
responded you can show this here now
to david uh
with this twitter link
which yeah here it is uh
all cases which shows
i'm not remember exactly where this is
from all cases are categorized as unvacs
until they find a matching fax record
all unknowns remain
classified as unvaxed this inflates the
unvax numerator and deflates the vax
numerator
and um
and then there's age adjustment that we
can't see so this is just this is the
receipts on this cases that don't match
to a vaccination record are classified
as unvaccinated including unknowns is
from the new york city
uh thing and
yeah it goes it goes on and on i can
spend time here so you can give that
that back to me but um
i mean of course they are
right like
in a city i don't know what the numbers
are supposedly in new york new york
state
but if
if a majority of people are vaccinated
and they can't and someone has claimed
to be vaccinated
and they've come in with coven
regardless of whether they've come and
committed they come in with meningitis
they've come in with a scraped knee
whatever it is
if a majority of people are vaccinated
and a person has claimed that they are
vaccinated the default assumption should
be that they're vaccinated i mean in
fact you don't even need the second
point if a majority of people are
vaccinated within a population and you
don't know what default to put them into
then the default is you put them into
the vaccinated camp
if they're also claiming that they're
vaccinated you of course put them in the
vaccinate camp but
but we're not going to do that are we oh
we're just being cautious no you're not
you've picked a default that has no
logical basis and it feeds your
narrative
so i don't even know
why we end up here
the
number of instances in which a measure
has been misstructured so as to report a
particular
sacred story
is huge right we've seen this across
everything and then we've seen other
efforts to specifically avoid collecting
the evidence that would tell you whether
or not that narrative was right yeah
right the failure to do autopsies for
example and people who've had
adverse events yeah
so yes
the problem is this is so obvious
i don't understand why every
statistician in the world is not
screaming about what has happened with
the data here even if they're believers
right there's no way that somebody who
knew what they were doing could be
organically fooled by this level of what
is obviously not incompetence these are
errors that all go in one direction
and
so anyway we get blue in the face trying
to say well but you know check out this
measure and you know
yes there's no reason we should be
getting horse trying to explain this oh
my god yes transparent
and it is i mean unfortunately you know
we unfortunately
we haven't been talking nearly as much
over the last several months on the
podcast about what we're finding in the
literature
because it's just so [ __ ]
untrustworthy
like it's
it's just
it's just almost impossible to do it at
that level and i want to say before it
disagrees
kathy says i feel like we are living in
the theater of the absurd suddenly that
made sense as an art form i had exactly
this thought i actually i loved theater
of the absurd and i have a lot of um
plays we actually had a two of our dear
friends read a
section from rosencrantz and
guildenstern and dead stoppard's play at
our wedding um the opening scene the
coin flip
and i've got a lot of unesco and um
and other
um other playwrights on my shelf and i i
was i went looking for some relevant
passage to read on darkhorse a few
months ago and just couldn't
it's just too absurd but like it just
doesn't make sense out of context and i
think maybe that was the point and maybe
i should make that point like i i wanted
to read a section
to point out that this is like theater
of the absurd but out of context it
doesn't make sense and i i fear that
that's what's gonna happen here right
like what we're live what we're all
living through right now
won't be believed it just doesn't make
sense out of context
well
this this is my point about about orwell
is that the problem with orwell is that
it sounds too preposterous to happen so
it sounds like it must be an
exaggeration and the point is it
actually turns out it isn't one right in
fact we're actually arguing over whether
two plus two equals four
uh so
yes it's it's almost impossible it's
going to be almost impossible to
preserve
the sense of absurdity and the inability
to establish the most basic facts or
rules of engagement or anything or
rights yeah right
uh so i don't i don't know what to do
about it but there is something hopeful
in this time
the size of the population that has seen
it
and this is why we're fighting about joe
rogan yeah that's right
and you know
i have grave concerns about what's going
to happen there because zero is a
special number and rhodium is the reason
we're not at zero yep
yep
do
virologists understand so well the
relationship between genotype and
phenotype of a virus that they would
know which mutations would render it
milder without testing it on people
thus making feasible brett's white hat
hacker for omicron
hey guys that was a clip from our
monthly private q a that you can get
access to at my heather heing's patreon
and you can also get access there to all
of the past paid subscriber content so
please consider joining us there
did you mention that these private q as
are the key to living a better life and
living to tell the tale i forgot to do
that these private q and a's are in fact
the key to living a better life and what
living to tell the tale living to tell
the tale
go ahead live to tell the tale join us
there see ya